[Music]
Katya's submitted by li exclamation mark
a man was arrested after police found
nine dismembered bodies stashed inside
his apartment what that reminds me of
Dexter he was just hungry Oh Dexter with
specimens bought in his body just like
dismembered being dismembered there's a
Japanese cannibal guy that kills
somebody in Europe and then he
dismembered the body I think he was like
a group college study oh you showed me
this diary and if he chopped up her yeah
that sounds familiar they're in a study
group together and then he froze it and
he liked to eat it it was amazed at how
fat how much fat there was in the butt
or something like that
yeah that was his favorite part of the
body what he went he got extradited to
Japan but then Japan couldn't really
trial him because under their law if the
crime was committed in another country
and now he just kind of just lives in
Japan hasn't really ate anyone but the
other country they couldn't since the
Japan laws like does he seasoned the
meat
does he like grill the human Mearing
it's a wrong oh no he no he grills it
but I don't know if it's seasoned or
anything like that
but he looks weird - he looks like he
eats people yeah he looks weird and he
dresses weird and he know this is the
weird [ __ ]
well this guy is also Japanese oh my
Japanese people love eating meat of
humans and [ __ ] and this guy ate the
bot I don't know oh no he added that oh
this story is about Takahiro she - she
he's 27 wishy-washy Bulls are busy sushi
so this all was discovered when police
were searching for a 23 year old woman
she had been missing her brother said
that he reported her missing her brother
was able to hack into her Twitter
account and that's when they discovered
that she was in communication with
takehito and then they had they were
exchanging messages saying that she
wanted to
and he was like well how about you come
over here and we'll die together Oh at
least went to his home and that's when
they discovered 9 to a women one male
and he said like he just admitted to
everything he were just like yeah I've
killed nine people since I moved into
this apartment on August 22nd but prior
to moving he did from a queen that's
another full bodies how did he keep it
like not rock the probably is not the
asking one or the question is Japanese
people are so honorable
it's a resume kid on the side targeting
people on Twitter that would tweet out
like that they wanted to die also he was
doing them a favor suicide hotline so
Japanese people he's much a nonprofit
organization [ __ ] let me kill you
you know that's so crazy he's just like
he found a way to help people but break
the law I was thinking that too but then
I found out this other part where I was
like okay now he's not a good person
because he's yeah also admitted that he
had assaulted some of the women with the
intent to rape them it's like you even
mentioned that when they're dead like
there's no other testimony he just keeps
coming I just saw honorable remember
what I said
Dexter cuz Dexter killed serial killers
but he's just a weird [ __ ] up even
more [ __ ] a version of Dexter because
he has to get rid of his his desire to
kill somebody and murder somebody but he
can only do it within his moral code of
killing people anyway that's what he's
saying [ __ ] him creepier
yeah and so you're saying that he
couldn't throw the bodies away cuz
they're too delicious because he was
scared of being caught so he would just
chop up these bodies in his bathroom and
then he said like some of the some body
parts he threw in the garbage but then
other ones here just kept my cooler like
cold storage containers yeah and so yeah
this nasty this is great because this is
like a serial killer in Japan which is
hella rare so how did they find the body
but when they went searching for the
sister and then they asked excuse me
yes I killed everybody like that and
to assault and rape - yeah hi are you
calm I was waiting these things but he
did and he also admitted that the
feeling money was one of the reasons as
to why he was killing these people - so
he would take the money I mean you could
have just stole that's [ __ ] crazy you
know what's um pretty insane about
Japanese prison so like he's definitely
gonna go to debt death row right so on
there's death row in Japan yeah so if if
you if you're if you have death row like
death row if you're so so they don't
tell you when you're gonna die so as a
surprise since you it's a [ __ ]
surprise so people in there they live
every [ __ ] day like today might be
that yeah well it might be cruel and
unusual punishment in the US but for
them it's kind of like you did the deed
you [ __ ] up on life yeah so now like
you're not a human you basically have to
suffer the consequences there because
Jamal Yin you know it's kind of like you
know I for an eye and if the person you
killed didn't know that was their last
day because most people that die don't
know the last day theoretically as a
prisoner on death row you would think
you wouldn't know your last day either
right I think the philosophy behind it
is yours you should be grateful that
you're living today because today you
got to live one more day it's like a
constant reminder that you [ __ ]
killed someone and then you should be
happy because you get another day so
it's pretty tired yeah it's it's there's
a documentary on YouTube you could watch
it but they literally just wake up like
[ __ ] okay it's a normal day and then
some people they get sentenced and taken
away and all that or like they already
sentence but they get taken away and
then put the chamber or whatever I know
this guy damn dude his neighbors found
it weird
why is he look like he's sleeping but
he's awake what the [ __ ]
so they were saying that his neighbors
found it weird that he always kept a
ventilation fan on and that whenever
they passed by his apartment I would
smell so bad
oh that's just probably like the
apartment
what was this that like in Japan what
partner Tokyo near Tokyo Wow
dad that's crazy man can you keep living
your life normally when there's like
bodies decomposing your apartment like I
can watch like a movie like saw and for
the next like four hours that's I
watched that movie I'm not eating I'm
like a movie with Ryan Reynolds yeah he
had severed heads in his fridge but he
saw them I like happy clean things maybe
that's easy they don't see like my he's
talking to the dead bodies very very
lucky that I'm a very you like terribly
lazy ass human being because everything
that I do I want to do that requires the
least amount of work so if even if I was
a serial and had the urge to kill
somebody the thought alone of having to
dismember a body already deters me so
[ __ ] dissemble this body I'm not
gonna be I mean even like in the wild
weird psycho [ __ ] we need food
I need a kill this animal looking for
berries dude I'm looking for berries
roots much view for animals just fall
down yeah hoping like something happens
man yeah he's got the Batman turn yeah
you just ruined Batman for me Batman
what which is like every time I get into
a fight I get hit the back of the head
peripheral vision every time Batman runs
into the alleyway and he needs to shoot
the little thing up like Michael Keaton
very much so there's so many impractical
like superhero costumes out there that's
like why do you wear that [ __ ] like well
if you want to be bulletproof and you
can't move
but anyways this guy Joe they're saying
that they did find a saw that they
believe was the one that he would use oh
they believe in God it's [ __ ] manual
too then some assuming it's not like the
worry-free that's so crazy
oh my god this is I know this is like
the reason why I'm so fascinated with
Dexter like it was such a weird show
yeah the first like four seasons was
like I couldn't place how it this guy's
a little different yeah I use a piece
[ __ ] but like what Dexter it was so
weird cuz he was like finding through
his murders he was finding his human
side that he couldn't he didn't have
before so as he continued to kill and as
he continued to grow as a human being to
hide his like weird monster inside of
him it actually helped him develop as a
human being so you started getting
sympathy for him was just a shadow but
then he gives him life and he finds out
that holy [ __ ] I can't even oh his
sister I can't kill my sister I actually
have feelings for her like I love her I
was like oh [ __ ] those guys a
complicated deep character yeah and that
actor put out a movie right after that
was [ __ ] terrible oh so I watched
this other documentary in my psychology
class called I think it's called
interview with the Iceman so he was a
serial killer that the Mafia employed
and he's killed over 200 something
people yes which work and he says that
he just doesn't feel like he doesn't
feel anything no guilt no worry no
stress nothing yeah he killed people and
I feel like the way you kill someone is
also really big for how personal is it
are you like gnawing away at their neck
as they're like screaming or you just
Pat and they're done no like he killed
do Strangler like he'll do stabbings
he'll do oak get me whatever is
requested to like if the Mafia tells him
like I want you to torture this person
and then make sure whatever and he says
that's the only time he feels something
aside from
aside from when he had children so when
he had children you think he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about his wife or something
like that but his children he will never
he feels love he feels like he's like
but the way he sees love is twisted to
Eagles I love my children
I'll kill for them it's like [ __ ] like
you know life's weird cause like I think
like I mean just to watch in the desert
so it's like he they killed because that
was the only time he felt like he was
alive why he felt human was because he
was murdering somebody
and that's when he would feel emotion
and that's what he wanted to feel that's
why he had to kill which is so odd it
was a need that he had to feed right
yeah exactly I mean they probably
studied a lot of Psychopaths or whatever
to create that character because that is
the common thing like a lot of them just
don't feel anything what do you think
it's worse not feeling anything or those
that actually get like sexual pleasure
out of like mutilating bodies and [ __ ]
which one do you think they saw
someone's arm and they bust a nut in
their pants like there was this one
cartel this female cartel girl that she
was like like she got she topped off
some dudes head and started making the
head go down on her and chilling twin
[ __ ] [ __ ] weird I would just say
they're very crazy same I didn't the
same to me if you're killing someone
you're killing something it's just
you're getting off in a different way
no I think like one you chop off their
head and you're getting off emotionally
the other person is just chopping off
the head and getting off sexually but to
me it's still you to get off and
whatever you need to get off and you're
still killing someone to do that is like
the ones that just don't feel nothing
like not even any satisfaction out of
killing you just they just do it they
could just kill that's it it's like
flipping a light switch for them yeah
that's sad yeah that's kind of sad cuz I
can't even kill a bug
[Music]